[Musique]
savez vous que les gens avec qui vous
interagissez sur twitter ne sont pas
toujours de vraies personnes certains
sont des robots oui des robots virtuels
qu'on appelle plus communément des
bottes des bottes ses décomptes
automatisé créé pour influencer les
débats sur les réseaux sociaux les
bottes sont programmées à l'avance pour
partager massivement des messages avec
un mot clic précis ou encore pour
partager tous les messages qui
contiennent le mot clic choisi les
bottes agissent souvent en groupe c'est
à dire que des dizaines et des dizaines
de comptes peuvent être programmés pour
tous partagé le même message en même
temps les bottes sont souvent utilisés à
des fins politiques soit pour attaquer
un politicien ou encore pour faire
mousser la popularité de londres c'est
pas toujours évident de reconnaître des
bottes mieux quelques indices par
exemple les bottes utilisent des fausses
photos et défauts l'ontt profil ils
partagent aussi un nombre anormalement
élevé de messages parfois jusqu'à des
centaines de messages par jour
les bottes ne sont pas toujours
utilisées pour tromper les gens
il y en a certains qui sont utiles par
exemple il ya des bottes qui envoie des
alertes quand des catastrophes
naturelles se produisent ce que le
phénomène des bottes nous rappelle c'est
que sur les réseaux sociaux on ne sait
jamais vraiment qui se cache derrière